la ocupación que israel ejerce en
territorios palestinos es la causa
principal de violencia e inestabilidad
en esta región a esta conclusión llegó
una comisión independiente del consejo
de derechos humanos de la onu de
naciones unidas- en cuyo primer informe
sostiene que poner fin a la ocupación
israelí es fundamental para alcanzar una
solución al conflicto aunque eso no
sería suficiente ante asentamientos de
colonos el bloqueo en gaza o la
discriminación general hacia los
palestinos la comisión insta a israel a
abandonar los diferentes estados civiles
derechos y protección legal que hoy
aplica contra palestinos y minorías
árabes en palabras de los tres miembros
que firman este informe y que proceden
de india sudáfrica y australia existe
una cultura de impunidad en israel que
impide a su vez que el estado hebreo se
vea obligado a terminar con la ocupación
por el contrario la acusa de buscar el
control total de los territorios
palestinos y al mismo tiempo denuncian
tanto la autoridad nacional palestina
como a hamás de no estar comprometidos
con el cumplimiento de derechos humanos
en cisjordania y gaza y también de sacar
provecho de éste
la respuesta de israel no se hizo
esperar el ministerio de asuntos
exteriores calificó el informe de
sesgado y unilateral y que forma parte
de una cacería de brujas del consejo de
derechos humanos de la onu la comisión
se formó en 2021 tras los bombardeos
entre israel y hamas y este primer
reporte será debatido en la segunda
sesión anual del consejo el próximo 13
de junio cualquier resolución que salga
de ese organismo recordemos no es
jurídicamente vinculante